no so you want him to be again disgust
Factor I'm not here for it I'm from
Zimbabwe I came here when I was 14. so I
grew up on like when you watch an advert
it's like an ads AIDS campaign video
something like oh you have to get your
partner tested so it's like ingrained in
me like I'm not here for that I don't
wanna like ask you can you go to the
clinic and get checked no but as long as
I'm not here for that let's let's say
you like him and you trust him right you
trust his word so if he says okay like
I'll always use protection I'd never put
you at risk right
but obviously understand it's amazing
that you know you've done that for
yourself but obviously the average
person that we live in very different
times right now the
one asked him to do something in this
level
like to me it's like a self-control
problem
for him
yeah
it's a heart it's a very hard sell I
think I know that's why it's difficult
because it's like saying because I think
it's like if he knows he's a like to be
with you he has to go vegan yeah but the
commitment doesn't start if you're quite
traditional commitment doesn't start
till that rings on your finger yeah not
really yeah so until that rings on your
finger he's not committed to you yeah
you need to know each other right yeah
but you're saying that even when he's
not committed to you you don't want him
he want him to be I would prefer that he
doesn't do that I know but is it a
write-off for you
it would be that's a hard seller I know
I know I'm well aware of that yeah so
um would you be would you marry a guy
quickly
so he he's yeah because I know
Christians
that's what Christians do all the time
they'll get married and like like okay
three months three months would you
marry it you just met him three months
later would you put
it depends yeah I probably would okay I
know people have done it I probably it
really depends on a lot of things okay
yeah but put a one in the chat if you're
trying to
would you also be open to
um an arranged marriage if your parents
found someone that that they could then
bring you guys together both I would
only trust my dad to do that I wouldn't
trust my mom I love her I love her but
I'm interested yeah dad knows best have
you dated outside of the church or would
you only date a guy in the church I've
dated outside the church before yeah
okay just to see okay what is it like
someone in the chat said virgins tend to
try to date men who are bad boys or men
outside the church I don't like bad boys
no okay I've never liked bad boys I like
it sounds weird but I like squares I
don't like emotional anxiety from
someone so bad boys they bring anxiety I
don't like that okay okay fair enough
that's that's really good that's like
very impressive
um I'm gonna read Superstar up for a
second you're gonna get all these people
in love with you
oh I can pull up the chalk oh yeah
that's great thank you can you just
remind the chat what the chart was okay
guys so um
Ash is going to show um the sexual
market value chart and this is a chart
made by Rolo tomasi basically showing
um men and women's value in the dating
Market
so yeah this is what we were talking
about earlier if you guys wanted to see
it
do you want to talk us through it before
we read a super chat
um no I mean I don't know what else what
are you talking about do you guys agree
with the chart like you would say at 22
is most girls Peak yeah yeah so 22 most
girls P okay would you say it would you
have to alone or within that range
roughly
okay would you say you're left over by
35 yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this is the
most biggest geriatrics
geriatric pregnancy is like 35 or 37. I
think it depends it depends so for
example my dad met my stepdad so she met
him when she was like 34 35 and they
basically had a great you could say
marriage for like 13 years before he
passed away last year but he was
literally the top tier guy mechanic
earning all that good money but also
taking care of the family and yeah so it
just really depends on the person but
that's speaking to the mic but that's
more the minority rather than majority
so I understand that too so yeah so we
would say for the most part for the most
part yeah I think if you're um I think
if you're talking strictly physically
attractive then
yeah for I think for most women then
yeah they're probably gonna you know
their highest their Peak the season of
their Peak is going to be in their early
to mid 20s but
I think any man who is looking for a
partner knows that a woman's value isn't
just in her looks and so if he's going
to choose her
there has to be more than that and I
think just in my experience that while
they can be very attractive women who
are 22 23 a lot of them don't have they
haven't developed the mindset to be a
good partner yet
um so yeah as long as she's attractive
fine but yeah if we're talking strictly
physically attractive then yeah of
course my question to you then is that
don't you think if you find a woman that
is willing to be submissive to you you
can train her in the way you'd like her
to think in a certain way because at
that moment when she's being submissive
to you she's putting all her trust in
you and at that moment if she's putting
a trust in you then she'd be able to
listen to the things you say
do the things that you'd ask her to do
without little to no questioning and so
you can find a woman at a certain age
that you like with the beauty that maybe
you missed out on with another woman
yeah yeah and then I think I think there
can be an element of that but I think
there's and this is why I think men or
masking family compliment each other
there are things that women bring that
men just don't are not aware of they
don't they like they don't expect do you
know what I mean so a woman who has that
natural initiative to
um to be an asset to her man's life in
ways that he does he didn't even realize
she could I think that's something only
women can know if I'm being honest I
think there's an element of you can you
know guide her to be the kind of partner
you want if she's younger but and
regarding the training I don't know
maybe in Western countries that's that's
not very appliable nowadays because if
you go to university and you go around
asking them questions about modern
dating whatever
you're not going to find someone who's
very
appliable to train based on how they how
they view things and talk and whatever
so you're going to have a difficult time
with that so I wouldn't go to a
university looking for that person
but most of them were there like 21 most
likely that's where you would find a
bunch of them that is true I think more
so than anything you kind of have to
understand that if you're looking to
date a certain type of person it's all
about strategic planning yeah you need
to position yourself in a situation
where you can find the type of woman
you're looking for now if the type of
woman I'm looking for and I'm not saying
I am personally no I'm just saying if
the type of woman I'm looking for is
someone that
um is able to get on my page I probably
wouldn't go to university where yeah
um but it's just strategically where are
you positioning yourself to find the
type of woman you like or as a woman I
say it to my sister are you position
yourself
in the positions yeah to find the type
of men you want so yeah yeah okay I'm
gonna Read Super chats for a sec guys um
if you have a comment that you want read
said send a Super Chat all super chats
are going towards Studio updates we want
to get two more cameras we talked about
ish I think
they're talking about cameras yeah two
more cameras I know we got Isha camera
you guys are excited but we're gonna
we're trying to get two more just to get
better angles um on the people over
there like the far angle so whoever sits
there okay
[Music]